alpine
du tour de france après une échappée
une centaine de kilomètres infamie dabek
fois le suisse a devancé d'un peu plus
connu que le gars ni du renne qui a
néanmoins conservé son maillot jaune et
qui a en revanche creuser l'écart avec
ses principaux groupes
cette reddition de 20 heures sera
largement consacré à la petite reine
nos exploits des rescapés de cette
grande boucle un page spéciale présentée
en direct tout à l'heure de la plagne
par étienne ménard et jean rené godart
qui s'est fait cet après midi une grosse
grosse frayeur aujourd'hui sur sa moto
avec une chute assez sérieuse
voilà vous voyez les coureurs empruntent
ce resterait actuellement à la plagne
ouverte ronds dans un instant en
compagnie d'un autre invité prestigieux
jean claude killy
auparavant je vous rappelle les grands
titres de l'actualité que nous
développons dans le cours de ce journal
est tout d'abord en bosnie une nouvelle
et très très grave humiliation de l'onu
l'enclavé musulmane de srebrenica en
principe zone protégée est en effet
tombée aujourd'hui aux mains des forces
serbes
alors qu'amy endroits les militants de
greenpeace continue de narguer la marine
nationale devant le parlement de
strasbourg ce matin jacques chirac a été
chahuté par certains eurodéputés
écologistes ou socialiste
rebondissement dans l'enquêté après le
drame de l'autoroute a9 lé conducteur du
car espagnols ont semble-t-il pas
respecter la législation
il aurait dû se reposer le jour du drame
et puis dernier titre à paris tout à
l'heure mystérieux assassinat de l'imam
d'une mosquée du xviiie arrondissement
cofondateur fils tué à coups de
mitraillette
avant de développer ces titres retour
donc à la plagne pour un journal en
tandem
nous avons tout de suite etienne
leenhardt habitué à planer sur les
sommets
bonsoir bruno merci pour le compliment
il fait environ 16 degrés ce soir à la
plagne j'espère qu'il fait un petit peu
plus chaud dans le reste de la france
mais nous avons passé une journée
superbe que nous allons vous détailler
donc dans une quinzaine de minutes très
longuement en compagnie de jean claude
killy que j'ai le plaisir de recevoir
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le président
de la société organisatrice du tour de
france il ya des années que vous avez
fait rêver les français en descendant
des montagnes est on arrivé aujourd'hui
en voyant les cyclistes monter cette
montée de la plagne oui on a connu une
journée absolument extraordinaire là la
rumeur
au départ ce matin voulait que ce serait
une journée d'adaptation à la haute
montagne et en fait ça a été une
explosion on a vu ce suisse fantastique
je voulais une échappée de 100 km les
banesto remettre miguel indurain
quasiment sur orbite et devoir terminer
comme ça à la plagne je dois vous dire
que ça a été un des grands moments de
sport que j'ai vue dans ma vie j'en ai
vu beaucoup
merci beaucoup jean claude killy pour ce
premier témoignage alors quel est le
dispositif que nous avons mises en place
eh bien nous sommes à peu près partout
où il se passe quelque chose à 20h sur
le tour de france et il se passe
beaucoup de choses
d'abord jean rené godart vous êtes dans
la salle à manger où les joueurs
les cyclistes pardon récupère après
l'effort oui effectivement c'est un
moment important pour les coureurs que
ce dîner qui suit la course
alors à côté de nous richard virenque
richard virenque à la table de la
formation festina expliquez-nous richard
ce que vous dîner ce soir pour essayer
de vous remettre de cette journée
particulièrement pénible ben comme tous
les sens on mange beaucoup de pâtes donc
c'est des féculents long et c
c'est des pâtes après on mange des trucs
en semoule ou alors en entrée on peut
manger de la salade avec mais notre pas
est vraiment consistant en pâte
jean-rené on va vous retrouver dans un
petit instant je vous ai tout de suite
qu'on allait retrouver thierry clopeau
qui se trouve lui à côté de gens qui
travaillent encore à l'heure actuelle ce
sont les mécaniciens du tour thierry
absolument il travaille énormément ce
sont les hommes de l'ombre ces zones de
l'ong ces fameux mécano qu'il bichonne
très tôt le matin et tard le soir ces
petites machines ces belles machines de
course on les compare souvent aux
mécaniciens de formule 1 et puis on y
retrouvera donc tout à l'heure ils sont
trois les mécaniciens de castorama ya
frédéric il ya gérard et il ya patrice
et puis aussi souvent ce sont les
confidents des coureurs on en saura plus
tout à l'heure merci thierry et puis
troisième endroit où nous nous trouvons
ce soir et là nous allons changer de
vale dans la montée de l'alpe d'huez
patrick chêne se trouve dans cette
montée avec déjà beaucoup beaucoup de
monde patrick en prévision l'état tienne
bienvenue sur un monument au football il
ya maracana vous savez au brésil pour le
rugby c'est truqué d'avant d'angleterre
pour le cyclisme c'est là notre monument
la montée de l'alpe d'huez avec un
drapeau néerlandais est déjà beaucoup de
monde nous expliquera tout à l'heure
pour quoi on parle beaucoup néerlandais
dans la montée de l'alpe d'huez
à tout à l'heure nous revenons tout de
suite sur cette neuvième étape du tour
de france entre le grand bornand et la
plagne une étape superbe avec un double
exploit celui d'alex houleux et celui de
miguel indurain commentaires laurent
frédéric bollée un décor naturel
grandiose étape grandiose entre le grand
bornand et la plagne il y à 161 km à
parcourir et un homme va décider de
partir alors qu'il en reste encore sans
cet homme c'est alex sous le un suisse
allemand coéquipiers de laurent jalabert
il est myope
il a des lunettes mais il voit loin et
il voit juste derrière c'est la grande
cassure est venu bercy notamment
n'avance plus à cinq minutes de dessous
le indurain souffre lui aussi mais il
peut compter sur l'aide de son fidèle
coéquipier gerard huées au passage du
col de corps mais à 50 kilomètres de
l'arrivée sous le nez virtuel maillot
jaune les poursuivants dorine du rennes
se doivent de réagir
dans les descentes il n'y a en tout cas
du danger qui rôde une moto est à terre
les coureurs levitte
mais c'était juste rappel des risques
que prend chaque jour la route du tout à
la tête de la montée sur la plagne
gérard huet est lâché son rôle est
terminée mais il dut rennes peut le
remercier
indurain qui désormais doit sauver seul
son maillot devant sous le commence à
fatiguer normal les conseils sont
inutiles d'ailleurs ça les énerve
il s'est bien sûr qu'il n'y aurait ni
soudain passer à l'attaqué une
accélération qui n'a l'air de rien et
qui laisse tout le monde sur place
demandez à roaming heures ce qu'ils en
pensent indurain à ce moment est
magnifique en 10 km il reprend 2 minutes
à dessous le et assoit finalement encore
plus son autorité
la victoire d'étape elle est quand même
pour sous le il préserve deux minutes
d'avancé rignault rennes et se place
comme son dauphin au classement général
roaming heures jalabert virenque ils
sont loin et sur la plagne l'orage
éclate après dessous le gym du règne le
déluge voilà il longtemps après alex ou
le longtemps après miguel indurain les
cyclistes ont continué à arriver à la
plagne on va le voir sous des images
particulièrement dures parce qu'il s'est
mis à pleuvoir une demi heure environ
après l'arrivée d'alex bleus vous voyez
ici des retardataires sont arrivés trois
quarts d'heure une heure parfois même
plus après les premiers nous vous ferons
donc revivre toute cette étape dans une
quinzaine de minutes dans une quinzaine
de minutes par dont nous retrouvons tout
à l'heure bruno valat c'est à vous merci
nous retrouvons donc après avoir
développé les grands titres de sécurité
une actualité encore une fois ce soir
bien peu réjouissantes avec tout d'abord
en bosnie un d'événements très important
lourdes conséquences
les serbes bosniaques ont en effet pris
le contrôle de séverine cha une enclave
musulmane où vivent environ 44 mille
personnes dont vingt mille réfugiés qui
fuient à nouveau massivement l'avancée
des troupes serbes presque dérisoire
cette réaction de l'otan avec une frappe
aérienne de f 16 néerlandais ont
bombardé deux blindés serbe tout de
suite le point avec stéphane magnier
c'est l'un des plus grands drames de
cette guerre en bosnie qui est en train
de se dérouler loin des caméras
l'enclavé musulmane de srebrenica à une
centaine de kilomètres à l'est de
sarajevo
est tombée aux mains des serbes vers 15h
cet après-midi les 40000 personnes
réfugiées dans cette ville puis en ce
moment même dans la panique à pied vers
le nord où se trouve la poche musulmane
du tout cela vingt-cinq mille d'entre
eux sont actuellement massés dans le
village de potocari où les casques bleus
hollandais ou leur base principale
nul ne sait combien il ya de victimes ni
combien il y aura de survivants parmi
ces hommes femmes et enfants filmés pour
la dernière fois vendredi dernier par un
amateur les serbes n'ont autorisé aucun
journaliste depuis deux ans et demi à
s'y rendre
les casques bleus hollandais qui ont eux
aussi abandonner leurs positions et cei
semble-t-il d'encadrer l'exode des
réfugiés
c'est d'ailleurs la protection de ses
casques bleus qui a donné un motif à
l'onu pour demander une intervention
aérienne de dernière minute à l'otan
comme d'habitude les appareils ont
décollé de la base d'aviano en italie
pour bombarder les forces serbes
deux chars serbes ont été détruits
d'après l'onu en début d'après-midi une
intervention trop tardive trop faible
pour changer le cours des choses
les cerveaux d'ailleurs semble-t-il déjà
commencé une autre france yves sur une
deuxième enclave celle de zepa comme
srebrenica et zepa est démilitarisé sa
conquête ne pose guère de difficultés
militaire ce soir l'onu annonce que le
chef des casques bleus hollandais est
aux mains des serbes
l'otan s'est montrée inefficace la force
de réaction rapide n'est toujours pas
prête à intervenir
la population bosniaque anéanti le bilan
est catastrophique à strasbourg se
tenait un sommet franco allemand est
bien évidemment jacques chirac helmut
kohl ont parlé de l'aggravation très
notable de la situation en bosnie je
propose d'écouter les déclarations à
l'instant du chef de l'état la france et
d'allemagne ont fait savoir d'une part à
l'onu et d'autres parcs à la hollande
qu'elle était prête à apporter leur
concours politique et pour ce qui
concerne la france puisqu'elle a déjà
parti
sa force de réaction rapide sur le
terrain son concours militaire en tant
que de besoin à la demande de l'onu
bien entendu qui seul peut te engager
une telle action puis par voir un
premier commentaire à chaud sur ces
événements qui se bousculent et donc la
chute de ce mini ce cas qui est tombé
aux mains serbe est une réelle
humiliation pour l'onu sur le terrain
vague lanouf l'est vous avez raison et
on peut dire que la situation se dégrade
de plus en plus en bosnie les raids de
l'otan d'aujourd'hui on l'a vu quelques
chars attaquent et non pas empéché la
prise de la ville tout juste de
permettre de dégager la plupart des
casques bleus néerlandais la force de
réaction rapide et bien elle n'est pas
intervenue
le secrétaire général de l'onu boutros
ghali explique dans une interview à
paraître demain au figaro qu'elle n'est
pas prête techniquement et que la seule
solution consiste à négocier mais
négocier rien n'avance et il faut dire
que sur ce point les négociateurs ont
été habitués à ce que les serbes et les
serbes bosniaques joue avec eux au chat
et à la souris
alors comment avoir confiance le mot
retrait de la forpronu est de plus en
plus prononcé pour dire que c'est la
plus mauvaise solution bien sûr mais si
la situation continue à se dégrader si
négociation n'est pas possible cela
pourrait apparaître comme la seule
solution réaliste le retrait surtout si
les américains votent le congrès
américain vote demain ou après demain le
la levée de l'embargo des armes pour les
bosniaques
alors on va pas très bien comment on
pourrait rester à en bosnie avec une
telle situation
merci philippe harrouard autres titres
de l'actualité l' enquête sur le drame
de l'autoroute a9 qui a fait je vous
rappelle 22 victimes à ce drame a connu
aujourd'hui un rebondissement avec cette
révélation du procureur de la république
de nîmes
les repos hebdomadaire n'ont pas été
respectées par les deux conducteurs du
bus espagnol selon l'inspection du
travail qui a fait une étude
les deux chauffeurs du car espagnol
aurait dû être en repos le jour du drame
ces deux hommes mais aussi les
propriétaires de la compagnie
d'autocars espagnols eux aussi en garde
à vue vont être amenés à rendre des
comptes à la justice
tout de suite le point de l'enquète avec
agnès vahramian et pascal quint il est 4
heures moins quart lorsque salvatore
sanchez quitte la gendarmerie de vente
devant les enquêteurs il a constamment
nié s'être endormi au volant de
l'autobus
il maintient sa version c'est en
doublant le camion est alors qu'il était
éveillé que le choc a eu lieu lorsqu'il
roule en direction de nîmes pour être
présenté au parquet le chauffeur ne
s'est pas que deux heures plus tôt toute
la sphère a basculé jusqu'à présent il
s'agissait d'un coup de coude presque
d'une fatalité
les témoins du bus ne parlait d'une
faute ni d'imprudence cet après midi la
justice a reçu l'analyse du mouchard de
l'autobus les éléments sont accablants
non seulement pour le conducteur
mais aussi pour les responsables de la
société de transport les disques montre
en effet que les chauffeurs ont roulé
dix jours sans respecter les repos
hebdomadaire sans quitter le bus sans
même s'arrêter comme le prévoit la
législation 8 heures toutes les 30
heures de conduite le 10 juillet jour de
l'accident
salvador sanchez et son collègue aurait
dû être en congé en faible il entamait
le retour d'une longue série de cinq
voyages entre l'espagne et la hollande
c'est de son lit d'hôpital à nîmes que
david a réagi sans colère à la nouvelle
à ses côtés son père chauffeur de camion
la législation il connaît moi je pense
que ce n'est pas les chauffeurs qui sont
responsables derrière eux il y à une
société et des patrons des responsables
qui ont décidé de les faire conduire
comme ça moi je le pense qu'il ya des
responsables ça c'est sûr mais il y a
deux formes de responsabilité d'abord le
chauffeur parce que le chauffeur ne fait
pas attention à sa conduite
ensuite il y à une autre forme de
responsabilité une responsabilité forcer
les enquêteurs ont entendu aussi deux
des dirigeants de la société de
transport ils sont mis en cause dans
l'organisation du travail la justice
veut aussi savoir pourquoi le mouchard
de l'autobus a été en partie graphique
et cet après midi peu de familles
connaissait le dernier rebondissement
autour de la chapelle ardente
on pensait à autre chose ils ont envie
donc jésus ils ont envie pour les
catholiques majoritaires en espagne
d'avoir une cérémonie avec les gens de
leur quartier bornou l'âge et j'en ai
dans le khat anime une journée de deuil
au village de roquemaure ce matin une
cérémonie religieuse avait rassemblé
famille et gens du village autres titres
de l'actualité la situation à mûrois où
les militants de greenpeace continue à
narguer la marine nationale française à
zodiac du rainbow warrior est en effet
toujours activement recherchés par les
militaires à proximité de la tôle dans
le lagon est désormais barrée par des
filins afin d'éviter toute victime
indiscrètes le point avec josé blanc
lapierre et valérie astruc
toujours pas de trace du cinquième
zodiac de green la marine française
cherche toujours même à bord du rainbow
warrior qui la certitude et à
l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur des lagons
et nous n'établissons qu'un contact
radio avec les parce que ce contact
radio pour elle faire opérer et donc
c'est pour nous quelque chose d'inné à
utiliser quelque 1 400 cas vraiment
d'urgence si jamais la sécurité
quant aux trois navires de greenpeace il
croise toujours aux abords de la zone
interdite près à un nouvel assaut de mu
rue roy
mais les autorités françaises ont pris
les devants des câbles vont être
installés pour bloquer l'entrée de
l'atoll
le bras de fer se poursuit donc sur mer
comme sur terre hier soir l'affrontement
a eu lieu à muriaux à l'équipage des
services vient d'être libéré mais coup
de théâtre il improvise un sit in sur le
port en compagnie de monseigneur gaillot
lui aussi libérer les militants
écologistes refusent de quitter l'école
qu'à cela ne tienne les autorités
françaises utilisant à nouveau la force
contre leur gré l'équipage embarquera
manu militari sur une navette de l'armée
française cap sur le rainbow warrior
le navire a donc ce matin retrouver son
équipage
mais il ne pourra donner l'assaut car
l'altercation avec les autorités
françaises avant-hier a provoqué une
avarie mais les deux autres navires de
greenpeace pourront prendre le relais
les écologistes
non une riposte imminente et en france
ce greenpeace a organisé une
manifestation très spectaculaire à
l'occasion du sommet franco-allemand en
déployant dans le ciel de strasbourg un
immense ballon gonflable en forme de
bombe et en déclenchant des sirènes
d'alert extrêmement puissante
ce matin jacques chirac avait été
toujours à strasbourg chahuté devant le
parlement européen par un certain nombre
d'eurodéputés écologistes ou encore
socialiste
récit véronique saint olive gérard
dernier et le président de la république
empêcher de parler le parlement européen
était ce matin en ébullition avec les
écologistes et les socialistes mobilisés
contre la reprise des essais nucléaires
en fait alors est ce que le taxait de
rembrandt you lie qui dénoncent cette
décision comme irresponsable et barbare
jacques chirac a répondu sans détour
avant de vouloir donner des leçons à
tout le monde
il faut essayer d'abord avec son coeur
comme avec sa tête de comprendre les
problèmes qui se passe ici ou là et
d'essayer de les aborder avec réalisme
et non pas de façon idéologique mais les
pacifistes n'en avait pas fini et c'est
sur food alarme que le président jacques
chirac
accueilli en début d'après-midi helmut
kohl ont le 65e sommet franco allemand
si le chancelier a réaffirmé que la
décision des essais nucléaires relevait
de la seule souveraineté française
il n'en a pas moins souligné
l'inquiétude de l'opinion publique on
était bien loin aujourd'hui de
l'ambiance détendue de la première
rencontre des deux chefs d'état il y à
un mois à peine
la contestation de la reprise des essais
nucléaires par la france a donc
parasiter le 65e sommet franco allemand
selon un récent sondage en effet 95% des
citoyens allemands sont tout à fait
hostile à la décision de jacques chirac
en principe ce sommet devrait être
largement consacrée à l' architecture de
l'europe politiques et monétaires de
demain avec l'élargissement de l'union
et la mise en place de la monnaie unique
mais je vous dis bien évidemment les
deux hommes d'état ou parler de
l'aggravation de la situation en bosnie
je vous pose de retrouver tout de suite
à ce sujet notre envoyé spécial gilles
rabin à sarajevo
donc la chute de l'enclavé musulmane de
srebrenica qui était en principe zone
protégée par l'onu
gilles rabin vous m'entendez tout à fait
capable de dire que c'est un échec
cinglant pour l'onu ce soir c'est un
échec absolument indiscutable
c'est un échec qui remet en cause à
crédit ce qui restait de crédibilité
internationale en bosnie c'est un échec
qui paraît encore plus compliquée et
plus difficile l'action des casques
bleus en bosnie alors ce soir d'ailleurs
les officiers bosniaques de sarajevo
n'ont pas caché leurs interlocuteurs
casques bleus qu'il considérait qu'ils
avaient été trahis par les nations unies
à srebenica alors ce soir il ne reste
plus que cinq enclave sur les sites
protégés dont une qui est déjà réduite
de moitié ses biatch toutes les 500
passagers toutes les cinq sont bombardés
et toutes les cinq ont des morts et des
blessés tous les jours oui et qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire un mot de cette fameuse
frr la force de réaction rapide qui
devrait être en principe opérationnel à
la fin de cette semaine
est ce qu'elle peut être opérationnel
dans un tel cas pour notamment libérer
les casques bleus qui sont retenus à ces
moines et chats écoutez ça saute aux
militaires de répondre la force de
réaction rapide devait de vos personnels
après le 15 juillet le c'était
calendrier prévu ce calendrier sera
respecté ce qu'on peut dire ce soir
c'est que les serbes savaient qu'ils ont
joués remarquablement avec ce calendrier
il savait qu'il ne restait quelques
jours seulement pour prendre une enclave
ils ont mis tous les moyens nécessaires
pour le faire et les deux frappes de cet
après midi les deux frappes de l'otan
n'ont ni arrêté ni même retarder leur
offensive
merci beaucoup gilles rabin vous étiez
je vous
je rappelle en direct de sarajevo toutes
dernières informations en provenance de
l'étranger l'hospitalisation de boris
eltsine en raison de problèmes
cardiaques
le président russe continue dit on à
moscou d'assumer ses fonctions depuis
son lit d'hôpital
mais ses soucis médicaux relance bien
sûr les incertitudes concernant
l'éventuelle candidature de boris
eltsine à l'élection présidentielle de
juin 1,96 retour en france avec un mot
des affaires le parti républicain a en
effet annoncé son intention de porter
plainte pour diffamation contre le
journal libération journal qui a affirmé
aujourd'hui que le p r & co
propriétaires d'un compte en suisse
géré par un proche d'alain madelin
d'autre part le parquet de paris
n'entend pas donner de suites
judiciaires à la fixation du loyer de
l'appartement de laurent juppé par son
père à le premier ministre pour le
procureur de la république le délit
d'ingérence ne peut être caractérisé
puis je reviens à l'information que je
vous donnais également en titre
l'assassinât tout à l'heure à paris d'un
imam qui s'occupe de la mosquée du
xviiie arrondissement de paris
l'imam abdallah qui est sahraoui qui
était très proche du fils et qui avaient
rendu visite récemment aux islamistes
retenu à folembray cet homme a été
assassiné en fin d'après midi à coups de
mitraillette à l'intérieur même de la
mosquée du xviiie arrondissement
voilà pour l'essentiel des informations
qu'il fallait retenir ce soir je vous
propose de reprendre tout de suite la
route du tour d'aller à la plagne
retrouvez en direct etienne leenhardt
merci beaucoup bruno effectivement nous
nous retrouvons dans la salle à manger
du club méditerranée de la plagne que la
gentillesse de nous accueillir et vous
le voyez les coureurs arrivent les uns
après les autres nous sommes bien
évidemment en compagnie de jean claude
killy beaucoup beaucoup de coureurs qui
descend progressivement de leur chambre
d'hôtel nous ne discuterons avec eux
tout à l'heure je voudrais que nous
revenons sur l'étape du jour nous avons
distingué deux hommes d'abord miguel
indurain parce qu'il conserve et qu'il
conforte même son maillot jaune est
ensuite bien sûr le vainqueur de cette
étape le suisse alex houleux au terme
d'une échappée de 100 km il a il est
donc arrivée en vainqueur à la plagne le
grand bonhomme du jour avec françois
brabant
ce n'est pas qu'il soit mystique ou
particulièrement croyant mais le geste
d'alex sous l'eau sur la ligne d'arrivée
traduit bien son état d'esprit
lui qu'on croyait mode il emporte enfin
dans le tour à 27 ans ça ressemble à un
baptême car d'où leur vient de loin du
tour 92 exactement au pour ses grands
débuts dans la grande boucle
il casse la baraque un prologue à deux
secondes lignes du renne un maillot
jaune prometteur et puis plus rien ou
presque
l'an dernier fini 8e à paris en 94 sa
saison et blanche
et puis il se réveille et gagne cette
année le tour d'aragon et le tour du
pays basque
aujourd'hui sa première victoire d'étape
en refait un peu l'espoir qu'il était il
ya trois ans lui le rouleur peut espérer
un podium à paris s'il ne flanche pas et
si la poisse le lashkar double n'a pas
toujours été gâté par le sort en 93
il perd la vuelta le tour d'espagne pour
29 secondes seulement à cause d'une
chute due à sa myopie
aujourd'hui le suisse port des lunettes
et il l'a prouvé il a du caractère voire
de l'orgueil je suive pur sang dit-il
volonté de lui même et on empêche pas un
pur sang de courir voilà et pour saluer
l'exploit 2 ou le l exploit digne rennes
il y avait bien évidemment et comme
chaque jour tout au long de la montée
vers la plagne des dizaines de milliers
de spectateurs tous ceux supporteurs de
tous ces cyclistes qui sont montés dans
des conditions parfois difficiles
une journée à la plagne qui avait
commencé très tôt qu'avec même commencé
très tard la nuit dernière
c'est un reportage d'anne consignes et
et philippe iv 4h30 ce matin à la plagne
et camions de la caravane du tour
viennent d'arriver
c'est juste un problème en attaque là
c'est l'heure des logisticiens dès
échafaudeur et tout ce petit monde
travaille dans une bonne odeur de
croissant car le boulanger n'a pas chômé
non plus sept heures du soir hier
jusqu'à soit au lever du jour ça
peinturlure déjà sur le goudron
chacun y va du nom de son coureur favori
là il s'agit de bertine les camions sa
main peut empêcher de dormir mais c'est
pas grave c'est sympa troy bodie verdier
ça a duré une partie de l'après midi
6 avait promis en tout 10 la ligne
d'arrivée tracée
un peu plus bas on efface cochon en
maillot à pois jugée de mauvais c'est
l'invasion dans la spéciaux 5000
voitures sont attendues
vingt mille personnes pour la plagne le
tour c'est dix jours de gagner sur la
saison d'été est un bon support de pub
internationales mais pas du tour de
france au plan médiatique et relationnel
est classé troisième
immédiatement après le des jeux
olympiques qui n'a pas lieu tous les ans
la coupe du monde de football cette
épreuve nationale
si populaire en france qui déborde les
frontières avec 32 32 chaînes de
télévision dans vos confrères le passage
du tour aura coûté un million et demi de
francs à la station pour ce restaurateur
envahie par les camions de la caravane
la journée s'est avérée moins belle que
prévu mais dans l'ensemble élus et
commerçants pensent en sortir gagneur un
peuple qui dit je rappelle que vous êtes
le président de la société organisatrice
du tour de france on est frappé chaque
année par l'engouement de plus en plus
important pour le tour de france
oui c'est vrai le tour de france 2
le premier a eu lieu en 1903 et je crois
que l'engouement était à tous les
niveaux c'est à dire les sportifs que
l'on voit les champions adorent leur
tour de france malgré toutes les
souffrances les spectateurs le long de
la route ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux des téléspectateurs de plus en
plus nombreux j'ai envie de dire que que
c'est le vélo parce que le vélo en
france il ya 50 50 millions de personnes
qui sont montées à lyon sur un vélo ne
serait ce que pour aller chercher leur
pain et qu'ils se rendent compte
vraiment des souffrances que les que
c'est ce que ces sportifs en dur et je
crois que c'est le seul sport qui met
fin à cette relation
à travers cet instrument si vous voulez
donc nous sommes très contents et c'est
vrai aussi dans le reste du monde
puisque il y à 3 40 à 45 pays
aujourd'hui ces 147 précisément je vous
propose d'aller rejoindre tout de suite
l'homme qui symbolise sans doute le
mieux à l'heure actuelle le succès du
cyclisme à travers le monde
mega ligne du règne qui est dans l'autre
partie de la salle à manger qui se
trouve aux côtés de jean rené godard
jean rené oui petit ami gad qui est à
côté de nous qui vient de s'installer à
la table de la formation banesto
la première question michael on parlera
après de votre journée d'aujourd'hui
d'abord donnez-nous votre menu ce soir
je ne sais comment ça passe pas
c'est dans
la mer
mais je pense que nous avons fait la
paix ne chante pour le menu il vient de
le poisson la viande du poisson la
viande ou le poisson et vous buvez quoi
souloy qua non rêvant de l'espagne et
m
un peu de vin rouge d'espagne que vous
faites venir exprès veut c'est l'équipe
à des taux qui amène son vin oui non du
vin rouge a mené spécialement alors
mythe
alors me miguel indurain donc vous venez
de me décrire ce que vous mangez vous
mangez tout ça pour bien sûr vous vous
réconforter noceurs carrière une étape
extraordinaire aujourd'hui
alors vous avez l'impression ce soir à
la plagne miguel que vous avez fait un
grand pas vers la victoire dans le tour
de france les lyonnais de réponse et
beaucoup pouvoir que la marche bien on
ne t'a pas difficile elle commence dès
ce soir quand même vous avez
l'impression d'être en position de force
au classement général c'est nada pas
répéter les mots d'accueil et bien vous
avez une bonne avance au classement
général
on peut dire que vous êtes bien partis
après dix jours de course pour gagner ce
5e tour de france consécutif
si tout va bien mais là métallos
c'est beaucoup jean-rené on va on va
retrouver milliers ligne dure et une à
vos côtés avec jean claude killy dans un
petit instant je suis aux côtés dans une
autre partie de la salle à manger aux
côtés de laurent jalabert qui nous a
rejoint bonsoir merci beaucoup de battre
avec nous et est ce que cette salle à
manger finalement c'est un endroit où
les coureurs se retrouvent après une
étape c'est un il ya un côté sympa quand
même
aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu
particulier parce qu habitude on est une
équipe aux deux bars hôtels mais bon en
montagne l'hôtel est très lent on se
retrouve presque toutes les équipes dans
le même hôtel
ça fait parler de pagaille après
l'effort le réconfort 1 c'était une
journée difficile très difficile mais
bon le bilan est très positif
c'est un moment agréable on va manger
merci beaucoup laurent alors bien
évidemment on pourrait venir de cette
journée tous les villages traversés par
la course entre le grand bornand et la
plagne s'était préparé pour l'occasion
et s'étaient mis sur leur 31
c'est un reportage d'olivier sous et de
cécile réglages le tour de force qui
passe est une fois par an et ça ne se
rate pas alors beaufort a sorti le
podium et la fanfare des grands jours
pour accueillir comme il se doit
la caravane du tour au passage
distribution de cadeaux en tout genre
en attendant le bleu ton de quoi faire
le plein de ciboure pour épater les
copains à la rentrée de toute façon il y
en a vraiment pour tous les goûts de
lune
la longue attente sous le soleil est
enfin récompensé les premiers échappés
arrivent suivi par le gros du peloton
beaufort est un poids de ravitaillement
après la descente du col des saisies ce
qui est un peu de temps au spectateur
ébahi pour admirer les exploits des
coureurs très courageux un non pas moi
personnellement très bon temps de
trouver là la terrasse vraiment la fête
est finie leur est venue de tout
remballer c'est promis on reviendra l'an
prochain
en attendant il ne reste du tour que
quelques embouteillages et des routes
bloquées incompréhensible pour leurs
touristes égarés dans cette jungle 25
minutes
allez bon courage quand même et puis est
venue sur le tour
voilà nous retrouverons toujours dans
cette salle à manger aux côtés de
richard virenque richard vous recevez
une montagne de courrier tous les soirs
ça fait plaisir j'imagine oui c'est sûr
que ça qu'on a un peu plus de temps le
soir vers les 10 heures parce que c'est
à partir de là qu'on a un peu plus de
temps
je commence à ouvrir un peu le courrier
est dit un peu supporters et
supportrices qui m'écrivent et qui
disent un peu ce qu'ils souhaiteraient
que je fasse bon c'est sympa
alors c'est une étape il ya des coureurs
et il y a bien évidemment dans les
voitures suiveuses des directeurs
sportifs et des tacticiens qui met au
point précisément des tactiques en
fonction de la manière dont la course
évolue et se à l'abri des regards
indiscrets c'est un reportage de thierry
clopeau ce petit homme de 57 ans
français miguel echavarri n'est pas le
porter de belles idylles du rennes mais
sa tête pensant c'est le grand tacticien
déteste la lumière des médias la
question de l'interview bon courte
ce sorcier de la petite reine reste
modeste et ne jure que par son roi
miguel premier il n'y a pas de bons
tarifs ci a pas volé leur procès n'en
dira pas plus c'est une tombe comme son
prestigieux élèves
et pourtant la tacc de cet après midi
préparé par toute l'équipe elle a sans
doute été mise au point hier soir à
l'hôtel du grand bornand et chez barry
n'est pas le seul à cette terre cyrille
guimard le directeur sportif chez
castorama lui aussi je vous le mets
retint des maîtres tacticiens
non il n'ya pas de sorcier d'une
variante la logique on n'en saura pas
plus le petit homme de navarre lui a
retrouvé ce soir son roi à l'hôtel un
nouveau plan en perspective avec toute
l'équipe ben ali ce taux n'est indurain
si fort aujourd'hui
en at il encore vraiment besoin
voilà thierry clopeau que nous trouvons
maintenant tirer vous êtes toujours avec
les mécaniciens qui eux continuent à
travailler au moment où les coureurs se
reposent
oui absolument et d'écouté pour les
mécanos ces boulots non-stop tout à
l'heure tout à l'heure les coureurs ont
fini l'étape à 17h30
et puis eux patrice frédéric et géra
bien ils sont toujours là patrice qu'est
ce qui se passe exactement quoi consiste
votre travail souvent vous compare avec
un ancien formule 1 mais de telles on
nettoie les vélos et ensuite c'est la
grande révision quotidienne le reste est
une grosse différence entre la
préparation de vélo pour la montagne
comme aujourd'hui par exemple et les
vélos de contre la montre c'est plus
difficile pour le contre la montre
constamment de demande beaucoup de temps
où il de préparation et pour la montagne
c'est plus souvent les problèmes de
brackley qu'il faut bien choisir les
braquer et les montées sur des vélos
alors voilà donc merci patrice donc les
mécanos s'occupe des vélos mais ils ne
font pas que ça on va tout de suite
rejoindre le car tout de suite de
castorama l'on va retrouver gérard tout
de suite gérard qu'ici c'est ici vous le
voyez devant une machine à laver et oui
car ils lavent le linge aussi les
mécanos de casteau oui évidemment les
vélos on s'est tous les jours tous les
soirs vous avez vu mon ils ont eu
beaucoup de pluie là c'est cette fin
d'étape
bon ben c'est pareil faut nettoyer les
vélos les voitures et le linge
découvreurs donc vous voyez la petite
trouvaille
la dernière trouvaille c'est ça
maintenant dans toutes les équipes dans
les gros véhicules vous avez une machine
à laver un sèche linge et vous sécher le
linge en plus et bien sûr voilà donc on
va retrouver on va retrouver maintenant
le kärcher parce qu'ils les vélos au
karcher aussi à 20h15 même sous la pluie
ici à la plaine on va retrouver frédéric
frédéric ça se passe comment vous vous
levez tôt vous coucher tard c'est
difficile d'être mécano il ya le
le matin bien souvent sur les coûts de
cette heure on est debout pour venir
travailler
et puis le soir jusqu'à 8h 8h30 9h s'il
faut et puis bon on faut en fait ce
qu'il a à faire c'est hier le nettoyage
la mécanique
voilà pour les mécaniciens s'occupe de
l'intendance mots si parfois ils sont
les confidents des coureurs vous arrive
d'avoir des confidences ouais ben on est
on est bien placé étant donné que bon on
est premiers à les voir pratiquement en
même temps que les soigneurs donc c'est
vrai que
on a des petites confidences ensemble
merci voilà bah merci oui on voit bien
que c'est une organisation qui est
parfaitement huilée pour une épreuve
dont on dit sans doute à raison que
c'est la plus grande manifestation
sportive du monde
et bien c'est aussi une excellente
affaire commerciale regardez le
reportage ce matin de patrice comme
neige le village du tour l'endroit où il
convient de voir et d'être vu
être vu c'est l'obsession des sponsors
qui accueille à l'ombre des parasols
voir c'est le plaisir des curieux voire
jean claude killy voir edgar grospiron
ou encore raymond poulidor on m'arrête à
me reconnaît seulement maintenant ce
sont les pp qui viennent faire signer
leur petit fils et qui ne présente plus
intense et elle est papa c'est quoi les
villages le pèlerinage convivialité
ambiance préparation a passé une bonne
journée pour nous inviter c'est le cas
aujourd'hui général rivière et qu'on a
nos jeunes pour la direction de la
gendarmerie
pour viviane it et décontraction
c'est ainsi que ce matin raphaël
géminiani faisait honneur aux
spécialités savoyardes que francis
moreau s'offrait une coupe spéciale
montagne et que ses collègues faisait de
provisions de paires de lunettes
ils ont tendance à consommer
malheureusement on en perd quand même
parce que des fois on les met dans les
mains dans les poches et lorsqu'on se
met en danseuse ont perdu est donc on va
en récupérer une perle matin le village
du tour c'est le réconfort avant
l'effort pour les plus jeunes le moment
rêvé pour aborder les coureurs cyclistes
et pour les coureurs tout court le
moment rêvé pour aborder les hôtesses
est ce que les gens doivent beaucoup
celui là non pas du tout
voilà nous nous retrouvons à la table de
miguel indurain qui a rejoint jean
claude killy jean-claude un mot sur
l'argent c'est aussi une histoire
d'argent le tour de france et la
réussite commerciale ne se dément pas
oui c'est une histoire d'argent parce
que le organiser le tour de france ça
coûte vraiment très très cher donc il
faut qu'on essaie d'argent mais mon but
ma mission et n'est pas de gagner de
l'argent mais d'assurer la pérennité du
tour de france et cela on le fait à
travers le sport grâce au sport pour le
sport on ne fait que du sport chez nous
et ensuite on regarde ce qui se passe
nous avons des associés des grandes
consorts des des annonceurs
nous avons une association aussi avec la
télévision service public en coin ce qui
est extraordinaire mais notre but c'est
la satisfaction des gens comme miguel
indurain et qu'il puisse vraiment faire
leur métier à partir de ce moment là
jean marie leblanc et moi nous pouvons
dormir tranquille le reste suivra dans
cette passion précisément on va on va
continuer à en parler en rejoignant
patrick chêne patrick vous vous trouvez
je le disais au début du journal en
direct dans la montée de l'alpe d'huez
et perfect dans la perspective de
l'étape de demain les places sont déjà
très très cher
tout à fait c'est très amusant de se
retrouver ici après le sujet sur le
village parce que là c'est un autre
visage bien c'est pas du tout le même
style serment campeurs les yeux aux
plats la néerlandaise je vous laisse
juger merci de votre accueil je parle
très mal de néerlandais je vous fais
simplement faire une petite visite ça
ressemble un camping côté de
palavas-les-flots autres vous baissez
une petite tente et les petits-enfants
qui sont là voyez je vous confirme que
je parle travail le néerlandais alors
des explications pourquoi des
néerlandais partout on va essayer de
comprendre ensemble en allant rejoindre
le seul français que nous avons trop
ville et par là bas pourquoi des
néerlandais parce qu'ici sur 17 passages
à l'alpe d'huez il ya eu victoire
néerlandaise
cet e mail que clippers auto malka
nouveau clip hey oui naines rouges se te
disent tous les néerlandais ont réussi
ici
alors ici c'est devenu un lieu de
pèlerinage mais j'ai quand même trouvé
un français c'est presque un exploit ici
qu'à vous avez même vu le grand panneau
qu'on vous montrer tout à l'heure alors
j'ai trouvé un français et c'est presque
un événement que faites vous ici il n'ya
que des néerlandais
on est deux on est venu voir retour
vous êtes là depuis quand depuis hier
matin c'est ça aussi la force du tour 48
heures ici pour voir passer les coureurs
combien de temps allez 15 minutes ou
peut-être dix minutes les généraux de
une heure ou deux pour les attardés à
vouloir sauter du mal c'est une passion
le tour ou c'est simplement pour
pour le tourisme pour une passion
j'étais en vacances dans les alpes je
suis passé du pouvoir la france bon j'ai
vu le tourmalet j'ai vu pas mal choisi
des pyrénées j'ai vu le tourmalet la
liane objectif de vacances voilà c'est
ça aussi le tour de france alors je vous
donne rendez-vous si nous sommes déjà là
c'est simplement parce que dès l'arrivée
de la plagne nous avons pris l'hélico
d'ailleurs jean claude killy qui connaît
très bien et d'écossé que nous avons été
bien secouée pour venir jusque là
pourquoi parce que demain dès 11h 50 sur
france 3 puis d après votre journal de
13 heures qui sera présentée en direct
du tour je le sais nous vous retrouvons
pour vivre en intégralité
l'étape de l'alpe d'huez c'est ça aussi
la belle association avec la société du
tour et jean claude chelli demain grand
spectacle sur france télévisions il a
toute la nuit la fête la musique les
klaxons et une ambiance complètement
folle merci beaucoup patrick est
effectivement apparemment beaucoup
d'ambiance et aussi dans la montée de
l'alpe d'huez que se sont écrites les
plus belles pages de l'histoire du tour
de france vous propose en voir un rapide
résumé avec françois brabant 1986
ces deux hommes font entrer l'alpe
d'huez dans la légende du cyclisme
bernard hinault et greg lemond arrivés
ensemble en tête dans la station de
l'oisans
le français est ce jour-là son
coéquipier américain a gagné son premier
tour de france
1952 le peloton découvre les 14
kilomètres d'ascension copie est seul et
termine premier à l'alpe d'huez où il
prend la première fois maillot jaune
fausto coppi est le seul vainqueur de
l'alpe avoir ensuite remporter la grande
boucle 1990 11e étape
quatre hommes en tête delgado breukink
et claveyrolat attaque mais ronan pensec
s'agrippe au maillot jaune au bout des
21 virages
greg lemon ici au centre frôlé la
catastrophe
ils laissent la victoire au sprint
l'italien gianni bugno qui récidivera
l'année suivant 1994
miguel indurain en jaune fend la foule
des supporters mais devant roberto conti
s'est échappé le transalpin est jusqu'à
demain le 18e et dernier vainqueur de
l'alpe d'huez
alors à qui le tour voilà pour tous ces
exploits réalisés au fil des années et
qui promettent énormément pour la
journée de demain
jean claude killy est ce que le comment
considérer comment considérez vous vous
êtes avait été champion olympique en
1968 tout le monde s'en souvient comment
considérez-vous un champion aussi
prestigieux que miguel indurain
quelqu'un dehors du commun puisqu'il ne
fait quasiment rien comme les autres
mais je vraiment c'est quelqu'un de
humble et je crois que c'est la première
fois de ma vie que j'ai en plus je
rencontre quelqu'un qui ne dit jamais
moi je moi je moi je
l'huile est intéressé par les autres il
il aide il est disponible vis-à-vis de
tout le monde
vis-à-vis de son sport ce qui est
vraiment très très important il aide la
promotion du sport qu'il aime
et puis et puis il est très attaché à
son pays à sa navarre et c'est là bas
qu'il va rentrer il émane de lui si vous
voulez une puissance intérieure à
travers son regard qu'elle peut qu'être
absolument fascinant mes gars rapides
amène des una opinion souple et jean
claude killy une opinion ce jean petit
qui lit un espagnol non pas encore
un ravin prévient une très haute opinion
bien évidemment de jean claude killy en
tant que champion mais également en tant
qu'organisateur je voulais vous
remercier infiniment tous nous avoir
accueillis merci jean rené godart
j'espère que tout va mieux maintenant
bah écoutez mon pied droit ne va pas
très bien parce que bon il faut le dire
j'ai une double fracture au niveau du
pied on est tombé dans la mode avec la
moto dans la descente du cormet de
roselend d'après midi ça fait partie
aussi du tour de france pour les
coureurs pour les journalistes et je
suis très heureux de la manière dont on
réagit tous les coureurs notamment
miguel qui était juste derrière nous
quand on est en baisse c'est c'est
touchant quand on aime ça quand on aime
le tour voir sa réaction toute heure
c'est bien merci beaucoup jean rené
merci à vous de nous avoir accueillis et
de nous avoir fait partager votre
passion et bien évidemment nous nous
retrouvons en direct dès 13h dans le
journal de daniel bilalian demain et
patrick chêne vous disais tout l'après
midi sur france télévisions merci
beaucoup je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée
merci et nous vous retrouvons demain
bien sûr en direct de l'alpe d'huez
proposent avant de vous souhaiter une
excellente soirée revenir sur
l'information que nous avons appris peu
avant ce journal 20h l'assassinât à
paris de l'imam de la mosquée du xviiie
arrondissement de paris une personnalité
islamique très importante puisqu'il
était cofondateur du fils vous propose
de découvrir tout de suite de reportages
de valeria strict
il était environ 18 heures 30 quand
l'imam sahraoui s'écroule touché d'une
balle dans la tête dans la salle des
prières de sa mosquée rue myrha paris la
fusillade fait une autre victime un
homme qui pourrait être son garde du
corps et qui a été tué lui aussi alors
qu'il tentait de s'interposer entre le
vieil homme et ses deux agresseurs
lui-même sahraoui était une des grandes
figures de l'islamisme en france et en
algérie
il fut cofondateur du fil et pourrait
avoir été l'objet d'un règlement de
comptes entre le gia et le 6/4 abdelbaki
sahraoui a toujours dénoncé la violence
des extrémistes
si son assassinat est bien l'oeuvre du
gia ce serait dans ce cas une première
sur le territoire français d'autres ont
tout de suite sur place ce tir et kurt
et thierry kurt et est ce que l'on a
d'ores et déjà une idée des
commanditaires de ce crime n'ont en
principe en scène des hypothèses il est
bien évidemment trop tôt pour évoquer
ces hypothèses ce que l'on sait
simplement c'est que l'imam abdallah qui
ça où il faisait l'objet de menaces du
gia
depuis le mois de mai il s'était fait
accompagner d'un certain nombre de
gardes du corps depuis un certain temps
vous entendez sans doute derrière moi
les sirènes de pompiers
les sirènes de police je me trouve à
peine à 300 m de la tente a simplement
deux petites informations il semble que
le nombre des agresseurs est était de 2
qu'ils aient pris la fuite à pied il est
utilisé deux armes différentes pour
commettre cet attentat
une arme munie d'un silencieux une
ensemble type de guerre où ils ont
braqué donc
l'imam abdallah qui sahraouis et une
deuxième arme sans doute un fusil à
pompe ou rabattre ce qui est
probablement l'un des gardes du corps
dans la rue juste devant la mosquée
merci thierry nous viendrons bien
évidemment sur cette information sur cet
assassinat dans le dernier journal en
compagnie de philippe lefait vers minuit
disciples fille qui reviendra bien
évidemment sur l'autre information
importante de cette journée la chute de
srebrenica en bosnie une enclave
musulmane qui est tombée aux mains des
serbes aujourd'hui et je vous rappelle
ses déclarations très importante de
jacques chirac tout à l'heure à
strasbourg à l'issue du sommet franco
allemand
le président français a en effet déclaré
que la france était prête si l'onu le
demande a mobilisé ses forces pour
restaurer l'intégrité de cette enclave
musulmane qui est donc que tomber entre
les mains de serbes de bosnie encore une
fois jacques chirac a bien pris et garde
de dire que cela se ferait si le conseil
de sécurité donné son feu vert
fin de ce journal bonne fête aux benoît
dans un instant là mais trio en
compagnie de ceux qui d'avant avec un
retour progressif à l'étang plus tard on
vous l'a dit demain à nouveau un 20h en
tandem les marteaux du don et moi qui
t'ai date très très bonne soirée à vous